Hi everyone and welcome back to
another VC libraries Open code review.
Today we'll be looking at another
PR implementing C + 23 features.
This is Part 2 of the stood expected review.
This is adding a whole new
header to the standard library.
The PR is 2643 by our contributor Misco.
Previously on the Open court reviews
and I've gotten partially through this
up to I believe the class expected.
In the header itself and the new
test and the new testing would be I
had submitted a bunch of comments.
Miss Go has addressed those and
reply to the comments that I had.
Now I'm looking at the the
commit history here.
There has been a force push which sometimes
makes it difficult to see what happened,
although GitHub is surprisingly
good at showing the differences
between force pushing.
So I'll see if I can do that.
And then OK, then we mentioned
there are some questions in the
the discussion history about.
OK, we're adding a new standard proposal.
Should we add other standard proposals?
And our answer is respectively
have been yes and no.
There's one actually mentioned
early on in the review. It's it's.
There's a specific comment for it.
I could find it.
It's actually my first comment.
Here it is.
There's one paper that has not been
officially accepted by the committee,
but it has been looked at by the
library Evolution Working Group.
They had a strong consensus
to proceed with it,
and it's currently being
polled by them right now,
and this is a fairly small change.
It just renames the member
function so as maintainers.
We've given you know approval to say,
OK,
it's OK to implement this paper even
though it hasn't been technically
voted into the working paper yet.
But then there's another one.
That Musk was asking about.
Monadic functions for
state expected that paper.
Although many people are
very interested in it,
has not yet been reviewed by the
library Evolution Working Group.
So currently we've decided to not
add that paper as part of this PR.
Just because so many times in the past,
we have tried to implement things in advance
of them being voted into the working paper,
and if they get changed,
or in the worst case rejected.
And they don't appear in the working paper.
Then we've just shipped something nonstandard
and we have to go unwind what we've done.
Most notably,
we were burned when we expected
to change to happen to still
futures blocking destructor.
That did not happen,
and so since then we've been very
careful about trying to implement only
what is actually in the working paper.
Plus,
really obvious fixes,
like if the wording in the standard is
what I refer to as unimplementable.
Vague or self contradictory?
Then we have to choose something
and in cases like that we can
implement things like library
Working group resolutions that have
not been technically accepted yet.
But in this case this does an extra
feature and is however good that
might be before it gets voted in
implementing it as part of this paper is,
I think, too early.
It's also separate.
Yeah, and that means that
implementing it separately.
Uh, it's just much easier in terms of.
Getting code reviewed.
Yeah,
yeah,
rather than as a large I think
this is multi thousand line.
Yeah this is like three 2980 lines
so that smaller is generally better.
If it had already been accepted
then having it be part of this
paper would be reasonable.
We would just be a single integrated feature.
We usually get catch papers
once they've been voted in.
Just get them all at once that
we don't need to worry about.
Like a intermediate point in
the implementation.
But in this case it has not yet
yet landed in the working paper.
OK, so with that, if it's all the same
part of the working paper, then yes,
there yeah this joint then yeah,
if it was like a separate header
that just works with then yeah,
having it is a separate very simple.
OK, I will minimize Casey here
so I can see more of the screen.
OK, so let's see what's changed.
I'm going to Alt Click to minimize.
We've got a change to the Navis, that's new.
We've got expected itself.
We've got the test and being added to
the include each header load matrix,
I think I'd asked for this because
it was a missing change last time,
so expected as being added there
and sorted order, that's good. OK.
Let's take a look at the debugger visualizer,
so this is used by the IDE to display
complicated types in the watch window.
So if you have something like a stood vector,
a representation of vector
is very complicated.
It's got 3 pointers.
It has maybe some debug data
members understanding what
they point to is not obvious.
Classes like list and map or even worse,
so this XML file the native.
Come out,
which is documented on Microsoft Docs
and helps the debugger understand
the representations of STL types.
So we ship it alongside the STL and
then it gets incorporated into the IDE.
So this here I'm assuming that Misco
is already actually tested this.
I'm just going to look at the XML
and see if this looks reasonable.
The format is you mentioned the
type you have the HTML escape.
Things like angle brackets,
so anything matching student expected.
Let me see what type that is.
Yeah, unexpected, let me zoom in a bit here.
Yeah, so unexpected of star.
OK, intrinsic.
This is a way I think to refer to.
Member functions.
He's calling it unex,
and this calls the function
under score capital unexpected.
OK, so at an exposition only data member.
It's Val and I don't want to
highlight Val in the paper itself.
OK.
And he here he displays it as unax.
That's interesting,
does that come from? Yeah,
I don't think that's a standard identifier.
Umm, so the the Convention that we've used,
and admittedly it has been something
like five or seven years since I've
directly worked on the visualizers myself.
I think Casey and Andrew have
worked on these much more recently.
The convention that I followed
back in the day was if you're
displaying a data member, or yeah,
it's going to get a lot of results.
If you're displaying a data member and you
want to depict an imaginary name for it that
doesn't actually exist in the standard,
I would put it in square.
Brackets, why can't we just use unexpected?
That's the name of the type.
The thing that it stores is in the standard.
It's called Val, or that the
accessor is going to be called error.
Right now it's called value.
The Accessor is going to be called error,
then depicting it as like
square bracket error.
Error could be more reasonable.
It's very interesting,
let me let me actually look at the
representation of the type real quick.
It's not like. OK, so uh miscues
naming the data member unexpected.
But if the accessor is error then
displaying the member as error Prem
Prem would be in terms of something
the user would directly see.
I think that would be a better name
but the error type is is error.
Yeah but this is not referring to
the type but to the data member.
Yeah, so I think that this area I think.
OK so we've got to come. Let's see dislay.
It's really the. This doesn't matter.
This is just like the internal name.
It's the item name here.
OK, this name or displays.
The data member's name I cannot type on
this thing as an ex but that identifier.
Doesn't appear in the standard.
Would it be better? To. Display error here.
Since that's the name. Of the.
Accessor number function.
Or possibly.
Huh?
Like
OK, this displays the data member
name as unex, but that identifier
doesn't appear in. The standard.
Would be better to display error
prime prime here since that's
the name of the ACCESSOR member
function or possibly error. Perfect.
Then we've got a stood bad expected access,
which is the. Exception type.
What does that have?
This ohh here we go.
This is templated on T and we've got
some by no this is what am I looking at.
This is expected bad expected
access void device from exception.
OK, here's the templating 1.
This an also has error.
And not anything else. OK, so same.
Same same question. Garden
name add.
For. Assess
Next up stood. Expected itself.
OK, so here I'm just looking
at the class definition.
Seeing what Stata provides and you
can access as value and highlight
again as value value and error.
OK, and then there's like
value or things like that so.
Let's go find some helper intrinsics
has a value value and unexpected.
OK, so we've got some conditions.
If you have a value show value.
If you don't unax.
OK, and then again same name here.
Aside from this, this seems reasonable.
If you have a value, you show the value.
If you don't, you show the error.
Yes, every single one.
So in fact I will.
Say just occurs below.
And X activated access and expected itself.
Trying to avoid too many
comments for the same thing.
OK, other than that this looks good.
This nicely switches between the two,
which is very good. OK.
And then for expected a void.
Because you can't really have a value void.
He just displays void.
That seems reasonable.
And if you put a. A literal string.
You just say void here,
but that's interesting.
That's extremely interesting so.
Oh no, hold on the display string.
You need to wrap and braces if you want
something like an intrinsic to be evaluated,
but for the item you dumped, you just.
With the thing directly there, display
string embraces item direct embraces direct.
OK, so the display string if
you just say void by itself.
And that's a literal string.
Is here and this actually gets OK,
so this is all?
And then only if you don't have value,
do you show the error.
If you do have a value,
you should avoid, but no children.
That's what the items are.
The data members are displayed as children.
OK, this all looks correct, just that name.
OK, that all seems fine.
We don't need any sort of.
Conditional logic from the
version of library or anything.
Because essentially if the type exists,
this is how the visualized.
Otherwise the type doesn't exist.
Uhm, it has never been revised.
OK, so that's good.
OK, let's look at.
This stood expected now.
OK, that's my existing comment about
updating our list of extensions,
headers and so forth.
I oh,
I guess I could look at what has changed.
Just a quick check that any other
comments were addressed before I
get to expected and the test setup.
That's one thing is we try to make
sure is that when changes are made
in response to code of your comments
that we actually go look at what was
changed and that the changes were
correct and not you know that they.
Or address 100% of what was
actually commented and that
nothing was dropped on the floor.
I'm not currently,
I'm not exhaustively checking each comment
I had mentioned against the changes,
but I think just looking at
what has changed will be good.
So of course the whole Davis is new.
We saw that the included Trader
loan matrix change is new.
We've got a test change this test
deduction guide. OK, that's good.
Umm?
This is this uses the idiom that
I am not a fan of. This could be.
I will comment that the the
full changes like yeah, yeah,
essentially I'm not a fan of the
almost always almost always auto
idiom because I consider it to be an
unnecessarily verbose in this case
saying student unexpected deduced paren
test error says exactly the same thing,
except we don't need the auto there
and it's reasonable when you already
have something that already has a type.
But saying auto thing equals
temporary even without.
But even if you kept the sign in form.
Just the auto and some
parentheses correct you.
Yeah, you don't need.
You could use the assignment form as well.
The copy in that form.
OK, that's a good point.
Stack asserts name is Decltype,
deduce unexpected.
OK and we'll comment on that.
That's purely stylistic,
I think I also need to comment
that stood is probably not needed.
It looks like this test is
already using the space stood.
OK, so I will eventually note
that and then we got a bunch
of changes to expected itself.
These are quite extensive.
OK, before I look at those,
let me actually submit that
comment against all the changes.
Quite trust what happens if I tried
to submit it on just the delta.
So in the testing would be 2000 lines.
The test is indeed already
using a space stood.
My favorite comment and was around 1:30.
OK. This test is already.
Using the space stud.
Additionally we. Eventually died.
The. Almost romance model.
Umm?
Production I.
And we tested.
Never directly or copy that.
Demonstrate like this.
Yeah I do. Why don't I first really stood?
And the variable name is deduced.
This.
Equal
technically not an assignment,
it just uses assignments and tags.
I wish the suggestions interface
would let you just edit the thing.
Yeah, you're here.
We just want to give Mr the choice.
So yeah, this test is already using.
Using this test is already using ASP stood.
Additionally we can eventually the almost
always AutoCAD or the deduction guy who
can be tested with either direction
or copying it like this unexpected to
do spring test error direct in it or
unexpected to reduce equals test error.
Copy it. Yeah, that looks good.
It's like oh, and it clearly better.
Is this one character less?
Uh, second one is 1 character more.
No one editor character.
If you put spaces around the equal,
yes, it's as longer. It must be longer.
It's more meaningful.
1 token less.
Yeah, there's a very slight
stylistic difference.
Not that I would ever comment in
a PR about it.
Usually I sort of mixed both forms
directly and copy it because I'm
familiar with the difference.
I I certainly don't blame anybody who
tries to rely like only on direct edit,
because copying its merit,
or I suppose vice versa,
although vice versa doesn't
work with explicit constructors
or clear that you're using.
The constructor.
Yeah, but those that have instead
of an assignment operator, yeah,
yeah avoids that sort of ambiguity.
My personal sort of criterion for
when do I use one or the other is if
the types are essentially the same.
I like I'm OK with equal,
but if I'm doing like a conversion
I'll use the parenthesis.
So like with a stood string I feel
comfortable saying string stir 2
equals stir one just to copy it.
But if I'm constructing from
like a conscious.
Are that's enough of a tight
transformation that I'd like to use parens?
I'm not 100% disciplined about it,
and it's not even consistent
enough about it that it's sort of
reliable to read my code that way,
but it's on things I tried to think about.
OK, so that was what was changed in the test.
I'm glance over were changed in
expected because otherwise I'm
going to jump past all that stuff
and just go to class expected.
OK, so here's the expected header.
OK, so we've got a fair number of changes.
Looks like some claim format stuff.
Oh yes,
I remember the stable name was incorrect.
OK, I'm just calling down.
OK, the changes here are actually
not too invasive.
OK, I'll just quickly read through this.
OK, so we're no longer
suppressing cling format here,
because that constraint is going away.
I remember asking to not constrain anymore,
so that's why we're just
unconstrained on error.
OK,
then we got some static
asserts that enforce this.
It's gotta be is object.
VE must be an object type.
Not Israel VE must not be an array type.
Not volatile and not consed.
He must not be seen by qualified.
And then our specialization
that all sounds good.
Friendship needs to be not with the concept,
it's good.
We don't need to wrap this
here because we're already
cleaning format off tier.
Yes, the off honor being removed in pairs.
Stable name is fixed.
This has to be auto.
Oh yes, I remember this was a
stealth build break because the
MSVC does not currently define this.
And we're mentioning the deducing this paper,
in addition to the renaming paper.
So this auto rifraff wait.
Why was that a stealth build break?
Isn't that the whole reason
we use this stuff instead of?
Ohh, it's because the if
that was added OK yeah,
the the the well the if was there already,
but MSVC currently does not activate
this and the stuff in here would not compile.
I think it's because.
And then the stuff in there shouldn't have
been even been seen by you see, right?
Yeah, MSVC wasn't Even so,
that's why I'm saying was stealth.
As soon as the compiler turned on that macro,
this code would be exposed,
and then we would fail to compile.
I think the error was that.
This was not deducing,
it was always taking a ref ref to unexpected.
But here we actually want perfect
forwarding and then since
the the value category also.
Ohh yeah,
because unexpected to not not gonna
be a template parameter yeah cause
yeah here here we're trying to
replace these four overloads with
one so this really does need to
be templating perfect forwarding.
So we really do need auto here
and not unexpected shouldn't.
Observe the return type.
Here could be our ref ref also.
Instead of Decltype auto and
then we wouldn't need the.
Thematically,
meaningful parentheses around
the return expression,
which is one of the things I hate.
In C++ we can strain.
That's an interesting question.
Go ahead should we constrain
self to actually be unexpected?
I do not believe that is necessary
because when we have the this
keyboard there it is the self.
It's got to be our class.
That's how PA47R7 works.
You could not just call this on
some other random type as a free
function or something like that.
Really quite confusing syntax.
I'm sure nobody else will get better wrong.
Regarding auto ref ref that is interesting,
I was about to think about the parentheses
and you're right that that without that.
Does it activate special rules?
Because this is not naming.
What's naming it data member?
Is that why it would directly
look at the type?
Because it looks like theses need to
be there to make this be an L value.
Yeah yeah, that's good.
That's instead of the declared
type of that member. Yes, yeah.
So what we're referring to here?
For those who are blessedly unaware of
the standard is the behavior of decltype,
which does not behave as
people would always expect it.
It's been designed to try to do the
right thing almost all the time,
but in rare situations things
like parentheses can matter.
And this is actually one of them.
Uh,
let's see if I can remember
exactly where without.
Isn't that behavior explicitly
opted into a decal type auto?
It's when you say Deco type,
so because we've said Decltype auto,
it's going to use the Deco type rule.
Could we not say that?
Yeah,
yeah and so that's what Casey
suggests is to use auto ref and
I think that's a good suggestion.
I was going to look up the deck
type rule which I'm trying to
remember without searching.
I know it's in my brain somewhere.
Member, it's really,
really hidden where the rules for
decal type are. Don't tell me.
I know it's here. It's not.
It's simple type specifiers,
even though it's not really
what one would call simple.
So under that here we go.
Declaration specifiers,
type specifiers,
yeah, OK,
and now they actually now
in the latest standard.
They actually break it out to a
separate section for long time.
This is hiding under simple type specifiers,
which was somewhat confusing.
OK, I got you with that
searching achievement unlocked.
So when you say deco type,
either directly or with decltype auto,
it runs these rules and
this is very interesting.
Because it does two things in one.
Essentially,
if you directly name the type
of a variable or a data member,
so that's this split here.
If E is an unpretentious sized ID
expression like X deco type X or
an unpractised class member access
like Deco Type M under score meow,
then deco type is the type
of the entity named by E.
So basically, if you've got an integer.
And you say that?
What's the declarer type of this integer?
Or you've got a data member?
It will just give you the type of that thing.
It would be very confusing
if it put a reference
there when you didn't make that
variable a reference to begin with,
so decltype does that,
and often that's what you want.
In other situations,
Deco type will variously return an lvalue,
reference, an R value reference,
or the type itself depending
on its value category,
and this is desirable because you often.
These decal type when forming things
like return types of a function.
If you have a function that.
We're returns the result of another function.
Then if that other function
returns something like an L value,
you want that to be reflected
in your wrapper function,
and the way to do that is to
return an lvalue reference.
Or.
Similarly,
if whatever you've called is
returning our value reference,
you yourself want to return
an R value reference,
or if whatever you've called is returning a
temporary like string one plus string two,
you want to return that temporary.
So that's that's what these
ballpoints are doing.
The tension between these is,
what if you form an expression that mentions
a variable like a parenthesized expression.
Then Decltype will use these rules
that return like an lvalue reference,
or an R value reference for L
values and X values rather than
just return the type of the thing.
This is one of the cases where,
like return RET is different
than return parentheses rent.
And the compiler will warn if you
do something like try to return
a reference to a local variable
that's about to be destroyed.
So in practice it doesn't cause
a lot of headaches.
But in this case it results in
sort of weird looking code where
we really do want the.
Give me the type of this expression rather
than give me the type of this class member,
but to activate that,
yeah perfect.
Anti.
And perfect anti forward and
I guess is there a turn type?
Yeah yeah it's yeah it's yeah
perfect returning essentially and
based on the value category itself.
But we don't want it to give us
the declared type of unexpected
because we know what that is.
So the parentheses here activate that,
but that's really weird.
Can we just say auto refresh auto
refi think is a reasonable here?
And if we can't say auto refresh,
let's have a comment as to why we can't.
Just none of us can figure it out.
Although this is correct, the.
The necessary parentheses are unusual,
and what's the wording in the standard?
Uh,
the wording is what I was just planning to.
It's this, no, no.
Of of the function that's
being implemented here here.
It's depicted currently as this,
with the four categories,
but we're sort of applying
as if logic and saying,
oh,
if we have C + 23 explicit this parameter,
we can make this fancier,
and eventually the standard.
Stuff might be changed to collapse
these into one the way that it has
been changed for explicit rule,
and in some cases if constexpr
I don't know if I.
Like doing this conditionally, but yeah.
Well the alternative is to just say,
well, we wouldn't do this at
all like we could drop this.
It would be totally conformant.
The question is like. AM.
Would we once we can assume C + 23
everywhere and in the center we can
once compiler support for this exists,
should we just unconditionally
collapse it to this one?
Would that be better for throughput?
It would be easier for users to look
at or essentially what we're using.
Too much high powered template machinery
for something that's actually not that
for those like explicit bool saves
a ton of headache and I want to use
unconditionally as much as possible,
but here.
I don't know it's I I'd love
to use this unconditionally,
but that's not what we're doing.
Well, we're we're we're working there once
I'm playing and MSVC both support this,
so it's it's imminent.
It's not gonna be OK, correct?
Yeah,
it's definitely a temporary thing right now.
MSVC supports it, except in modules
claim does not yet support it,
but I believe it's coming soon,
hopefully.
Hi, it's gonna be.
It's gonna be backwards support like
you want it's gonna be supported in
all standards modes no it will be.
It will be specific to C + 23 but that
doesn't matter because it's a 23 hour.
Yeah great yeah OK and this suggests.
Returning auto ref ref.
Let's case we don't.
Interestingly, there is a difference
between returning auto ref ref and decltype
auto or there was in certain cases when
we're turning like PR values where I
think Decltype auto does not attempt
to construction and auto refresh did it
may have been become moot after the.
Serious for 17 deferred temporary
materialization so I don't actually
know if that is an actual difference,
but that's not a concern here,
cause unexpected is an actual
data member that we have.
Although this is correct,
the necessary parentheses are
unusual and potentially confusing.
C Carter suggests returning auto refresh,
in which case we don't need the parentheses.
And. Since you're here. Our char
char char Cras kind of stuff.
Correct? I think Nicole was on the call.
If she supports this,
feel free to speak up and I'll add
your name to the list of signatories.
Yeah yeah I support it.
OK she support uses the template
type deduction with reference
collapsing roles so do it.
If there's some reason that
we have not realized why.
You can't do that.
Then there should be a comment
because none of us really able
to figure out what that was.
Yeah, that that would be real,
surprising,
and it could be like I just I
never know I I like to joke,
I used to know how the standard
worked and then I lost.
That's not completely accurate.
I kind of know how this student
works when they Add all these
new core language features.
He knows OK, what's going on here?
OK, we're getting rid of constraints instead,
they're becoming static,
assert is swappable VA nice,
human readable message.
You must be swappable,
that's great, this is just.
Wrapping constrained swappable
VE must be swappable, Yep.
Making sure that we're not adding no throw,
there shouldn't be OK.
That's all good.
Removing the constraint about
equality comparable.
That's all good.
Love the node discard friend.
And the deduction guide.
Yes,
I remember I noticed that this was missed
and then that first line test coverage.
Moving down there has exceptions.
Adding in the protected.
Oh yeah, I think this was this was
depicted in the standard, wasn't it?
Let's go back.
Out of the Scary Court language
into the library world,
expected objects to 15
separate sections here.
That expected access.
Why are these protected?
Are we looking at the void mean?
Hmm. The void one is supposed
to have default copy.
It's supposed to have all of
them and the ddor. So. Uh.
We're adding these.
Do we have a secret constructor?
We're making them protected.
This is on the Void 1.
Oh, here's the protected.
The void one is supposed to have
protected all of these things. And.
They didn't exist at all before,
so they were public.
That was the issue that was
the observable difference,
and now miss is making them all
protected and defaulted excellent.
And then moving down that non
standard has exceptional stuff.
OK, that's all good. I'm bad.
Expect to access this constructor is header
only and does not need to be clear this call.
That's correct.
We comment that it's strengthened. Uhm?
We need an occurs below for the yeah.
Well, this only twice right?
Yeah, it's probably only the twice.
And then Yep auto removing
constructs because nothing here
is constexpr or otherwise.
The change is saying.
OK, that all looks good.
Change this to set occurs below.
And. Uh, is that address, parentheses?
And all these accessors don't need constexpr.
OK, expected itself and this is
getting to the point where I need
to start reviewing this anyways.
Unconstrained and the
same with the friendship,
then a bunch of stuff happening,
so we'll get down there.
Anything else of notes? Stable name there.
This keeps recurring. Some new lines.
OK, again removing the constraints.
OK so just in in line with
everything that we've seen elsewhere.
OK, this is all looking good.
OK, so now let's look at
the changes as a whole.
So we've caught.
You make my test changes. Probably not.
I did look at the test delta,
but the only the only test
delta was the the guide.
Nothing else has changed in the test,
so if you had requested changes
the test they have not happened.
That is complained about
the enum class thing,
but nobody agrees with me on that so.
There's a resolution Charlie is weird.
OK, so you know, Clarksburg.
I guess we can take a look at where was it?
It's in the test,
it's it's in the template with a
bunch of non type template parameter
like you know class like all these.
So a bunch of a bunch of enum
classes that are actually bools.
And I'm just like.
Making them normal enums.
And having the NTP's be actual
pools would be easier. Umm?
Honestly, I disagree like I like,
even though it's highly verbose,
this avoids confusion.
The problem with if everybody's a bool then
your confusion is very easily as I know,
yeah, but this way it can't be confused.
And it's consistent with the pattern used in,
like the ranges test,
where there's like is common range whatever,
right?
Yeah, here's a case where like,
like the lazy thing is absolutely
to use bowls and we actually
have been lazy elsewhere.
This is like the more
disciplined thing to do.
Yeah, it's so, so I think it.
Doing it with rules makes the task
easier to read, and it makes them it.
Adds a way to screw operating them.
Hmm,
but would your concern be addressed
if there were shorter names for this?
Not really,
no.
It's yeah, it's like.
And also, that's kind of
weird to have these kind of.
School you know class thing?
They're just sort of like strongly
typed bulls, but yeah, I mean,
you know it is a sort of personal preference
like you're entitled to your opinion.
Others are entitled to disagree.
And in test code I will say I
care less to care much more about.
Not getting confused about
what things are fine.
I'm fine for everybody taking orange.
OK, sounds good, expected maybe I
should this this screen that I'm
presenting on is not quite big enough
to do side by side. The last time
I tried it was very very narrow.
Yeah, it's a little annoying.
I'll just flip through as necessary.
OK, so for expected,
we've got some type defs.
And it doesn't even offer like
2/3 and 1/3 OK. We get down here.
So here's my highlighter,
so we've got template on class
tie and class air class expected.
We can declare friendship
without an access specifier,
because access doesn't matter there.
We grant friendship to ourselves,
so every expected can access
every other expected.
That seems reasonable.
Probably need that for like the conversion.
And then in the public region,
we've got using value type as T
using error type as east using
unexpected type as unexpected error.
We've got a rebind template on
Utah using rebind as expected.
You error type. That's all good.
And we've got some constructors.
OK, I'm gonna check those stable lines
because we had issues with them before.
Expected object ctor, yes?
So we've got a constexpr expected.
That is being strengthened is no throw,
default constructible tie
cause this one does have.
System does have a value OK.
And then this one actually does
have a standard constraint,
so requires this correct to see
here is default constructible.
Vt must be true.
We value initialize Val.
We said has value to be
true and we can throw,
but we've strengthened the
exception specification correctly,
so that's all good.
Now we're going to suppress claim
form it off because Clang format
does not handle the complicated
requires costs very nicely,
yet I really hope that that will improve.
Which one is this?
Looks like a copy constructor.
OK, there's a copy,
sometimes explicit.
It's very interesting to see
conditional explicit on a copy.
What is going on here?
I especially it's differently constrained.
Yeah, just how far something going on.
OK so.
You're OK, here we go.
Is defined as deleted.
The constructors trivial.
These are the conditionally
explicit converting constructors.
What about the copy constructor?
That's weird.
OK, so the standard depicts this explicitly
below for expecting account expected UG RAF.
But none of that cflow stuff were
just the plain copy and move.
Is this just a mistake in the synopsis,
the class definition?
That must be a mistake from
the Ingress Paper. Yeah,
I would swear I remember telling Jonathan
to fix this during one of the code reviews,
and I'm guessing he fixed
the details but not the.
Synopsis declarations yeah,
these should be submitted
as an editorial issue?
Yeah, I'll submit it and add fix for this.
OK, you are awesome Casey.
Thank you.
Uh, OK,
so that's good because copy
constructors in the standard
are not supposed to be explicit.
So let's ignore that.
Let's just look at the definition.
OK, yeah, the difference there.
There was actually a since this.
I saw it come up on a forum thread.
An explicit copy constructor
seems real tempting to a lot of
people for some reason to be OK,
let's be clear about like when we're
accidentally going to copy values or not.
The problem is that the standard if you
give types to the standard library when
it expects them to be copy constructible,
it expects them to be
implicitly copy constructible.
Meaning that expressions like T.
Equal B where you use copy list in it
that needs to work and if it doesn't,
then the standard is free
to maybe reject your code.
Maybe maybe it won't,
maybe maybe it will accept your code.
It's possible, and apparently it does happen,
but you shouldn't.
You know violate the requirements
of the standard for no reason,
so types really should not have
explicit copy constructors.
The vast majority of the time,
and that's why we originally
confused to see the explicit there.
And I'm glad to see it is not actually
in the standard. So we've got.
There is a second overload here
that's for this triviality stuff.
So.
Let's get all this check so expected
cost expected ref other we don't
need to name the parameter when
we were defaulting requires.
So when is trivially copy constructible
V tie and is trivially copy constructible
of error when they're both true,
then the constructor can be trivial,
and we default all thing.
So this is good,
except that the parameter need not be named.
Maybe I'll comment on both lines so you
can actually see the equals default.
When? Equals default ING. Umm?
We conventionally don't bother naming.
The function parameter.
The idea behind here is that default
says hey, just go generate with the
compiler generate, so that assumes
that you have an understanding of
what the compiler would generate,
and so naming the template
parameter is not really useful.
That applies to, like the constructor,
A defaulted spaceship
comparison operator like.
We know they're going to take left and right,
so there's really no point in
naming the function parameter.
OK. Ohh, let's see.
So let's that's the trivial bit.
This one then needs to be
constrained the other way.
So, so here's an interesting
case where you can see.
The library is doing something
that is verbose and a lot of people
will look at it and with some
justification they'll say ohh,
look at how complicated
C Plus has become like.
Look, look at all these requires
that you gotta add and there's
there's some error to that
claim like this is complicated,
but you can also view it as the
library is trying to express
something that is actually quite
convenient and intuitive to users.
Like saying this constructor exists
only if you can actually copy
both the type and the error type,
and that it's trivial.
I think it doesn't generate
you know interesting code Gen.
If the type in the error are just
trivially copy constructible,
like they're just integers or something.
So saying that the constructor is
sort of transparent in some way
that you get what it would generate
without extra library machinery on top.
That would make it non trivial
or always present or something,
so these constraints are all good.
This makes the type behave
in predictable ways,
but currently we don't have
a super direct way to express
this in the core language.
So we manually construct it using
the system of two constructors,
one of which is defaulted,
one of which is implemented,
and they're constrained
in mostly opposite ways.
But this one also requires
copy constructibility.
Because if it's not trivially
copy constructible,
maybe it's not copy constructible at all.
And.
There's currently no better way to do this.
Maybe there will be in the future.
We've seen time and time again over
the long history of the standard
that when the libraries do very
mechanically repetitive things,
we're trying to express something
really elegant.
Actually,
a lot of this stuff is stuff where
if you deleted all the constraints,
there is also be kind of the same,
except that you get a failure from
kind of deep within the library.
Yes, that's actually good point.
You're just sort of pulling
that up into the constructors,
so the IT happens immediately.
Yes,
this is essentially what
happened for like a pair.
If you had just like a pair of T&amp;E,
you would get this triviality.
You would get the.
I'm not copyable if my data
members aren't copyable,
it's just you wouldn't get the
functionality of looking at as value,
which we obviously need.
Also,
the the thing that would generate
code like that would like.
Trigger some template that instantiation was
bogus was like in one of the base classes of.
You know,
like in some base class of hair or
something that you had no idea about.
Yeah, yeah,
so yeah,
you do need control over all
your base classes and stuff.
In this case we're not patching
over weirdness in the base classes,
but we are trying to restore
what the compiler would
do while preserving this extra
logic that we need because having
this means that the constructor is
not trivial and will always exist.
So we sort of have to repair what the
compiler would have done in the absence
of this in the future, there may be
a more convenient way to do this,
like I was saying there was a we seen
with like variadic templates and in fact.
Bring back to default default constructors.
Things like explicit operator
bool every single or an explicit
bool like the conditional explicit
every single one of these things.
The library imitated for years because
we were trying to reach into the future
and do cool advanced things with a
more primitive core language then
the core language finally caught up.
I sort of get the sense here with
these constraints that this might be a
case where the core language will make
things more convenient in the future,
maybe not.
Maybe this is too obscure, but possible.
So this is not as horrible as
it might look at first glance.
I mean,
we could write the constraints as
as as a concept and and just use
that in the abbreviated syntax
if we really wanted to.
Yeah, and this is actually just occur
often enough that we might factor it out.
Currently it doesn't occur
quite often for us to.
Factored out like tuple needs
very similar stuff to this,
but it needs to work with
like arbitrarily many,
so we ended up cancelling
a lot of stuff right?
This one's a little bit
different from people,
but there is the potential as
being more peer like types,
not to mention if it's not factored
out inside the standard then.
The reason why argument for
not factoring out?
Yeah here either yeah.
Then the standard usually does factor
things out if it gets real repetitive.
Well, that's interesting.
This might be where that Unex came from.
Why?
Why is the the standard he's
talking about next year?
When I thought it was Val,
is that the first here is unex interesting.
On X is the data member of the E
data member of the expected OOH.
Notice that does that mean?
I think that means one of my
visualizer comments was wrong.
It's only the expected that
has on X Now it's fine,
but it's the bad expected access
and the unexpected that is just Val.
Oh, but those might.
Those might get editorially changed on X.
And actually, it's Val as far as the
as far as the unexpected is concerned,
but it's it's unax as far as the
expected is concerned. Yeah, arguably,
if that one paper that has been.
Preliminarily blessed by
the library evolution?
Uh, working group.
If that renames value to error,
there's an argument for changing this veil
to unx or error or something bad expected
X is already has an accessory and error.
Calling them all on X is actually not wrong.
It's a. It was a little unexpected for me.
Yeah joke but you know I'm gonna
go get rid of that comment.
I think it's fine.
Users can always file a bug
if they think it's weird.
Yeah, this is fine,
but do you wanna say that, UM?
Because I'm about to get off the
bus and therefore will not be
on the meeting in a bit, but.
And what's that?
Requirements on.
Yeah, I think you broke up.
I didn't quite catch what you were saying.
I did yeah, sorry the requirements on
the non trivial copy constructor. Yes.
What about them?
I'm not hearing anything.
If you're talking UM.
The requirements on the non
trivial copy constructor.
That's this thing.
If you're not trivial,
that's these two.
OK, I'll take a close look at that
if you could connectivity again,
please let us know.
OK so I was going to.
I just switched to a different
network OK and the requirements on
the non trivial copy constructor are
incorrect because what it says is.
Not trivial copy, constructible T and
not trivially copy constructible air.
And what we want is good .1 or like either.
Yeah, the the the they need to be Morgan.
Ohh I didn't even look at that.
Yeah, let's take a look. OK. It's uh.
Requires not that and not that, yeah,
that that is not. That's that's wrong.
Excellent catch it doesn't.
Yeah, this is.
This is fine, but this is not right OK?
OK yeah, well what I what I mentioned
there was am a demogorgon's law which
is the Boolean logic law about negating
conditions that I think is possibly
one of the few things I would say that
every programmer needs to know because
it comes up so often more than negate
the conditions for requires causes.
I mean, it's it's a general
thing like nobody can change.
It's like not A and the change
the partial order I think.
What partial order?
The the the one used for subsumption rules?
Ohh, you mean for concepts not Morgan.
Ohh that's interesting.
I think I would have to defer to Casey there.
I don't know how though.
Those assumption rules work.
I don't think that matters here because.
You don't have multiple overloads.
OK, yeah, we've just got.
We've just got the two. It's the OK.
Let's see credit call because she
noticed this noticed that. The.
He is truly comparable constructible V.
Requirements here are incorrectly.
I'm not.
I was forget exactly how to spell
the Morgan's name is lowercase D.
Is it a capital DI? Think that's right.
I think it's not camelcase.
The trivial ones French,
we can just we can just make
something up because it's not.
I forget his nationality.
Now let's see X is true and Y is true, yes.
Trivial A and let me say T trivial T and.
Trivial E, so the implication
of that should be. Not.
Or not trivial.
And the. Additional. Constraints.
Excellent catch and that
is this is excellent.
This is an excellent example of
how code review can catch bugs.
Because this bug is very subtle,
you'll only find it in certain
cases where the types don't quite
don't produce the same results and.
Even in the case where like,
yeah, it depends.
Like exactly you know which
constructors are viable.
It's possible there could be ambiguity.
It's possible we could get
a constructor that compiles,
just happens to be nontrivial,
which is very difficult to detect.
It has observable effects,
which is why we do this,
but that's a good example of like
how code review can find bugs.
So thank you,
Nicole Nicole noticed that the
is trivially constructible.
View requirements here are
incorrectly to Morgan,
the trivial 1 requires triviality
and trivially E.
So the negation of that should be, not.
Triviality or not trivial ease,
and then the additional constraint
should be added to that OK.
OK, uh, this also occurs on line 205.
Added to that comment.
Good point. Yeah, the move, yeah.
You're also, you know that's that,
that's for sure there's task.
Trivial, oh, we can detect triviality
with this trivially copy constructible.
We don't need to like carefully look at
the code media asked the type traits
test coverage, just asked 40 days.
Just. Is generally.
Let's start with all etcetera to
inspect the existence and triviality.
Reality for all, and we do have similar.
We do similar test coverage for this,
where I think pair, pair and tuple.
I remember having a non trivial,
trivial or implicitly constructible,
at least for the implicity constructible.
Sure we have that we have for all the
new functions here that have kind of.
No no. Non trivial if you will.
This is such a rich source of funds.
Uh, OK. Casey also knows the next.
Ohh go ahead this has he checked how
this interacts with the cling bug
with conditionally trial constructors?
That one about the order dependency
coding doesn't actually implement
conditionally trivial constructors,
and it just picks the first one.
You knows, it just picks the first one when
it's disabled by the constraints or not.
Or what happens.
My my reaction to that is wolf.
Yeah what what?
What header did that affect I can find once
I know which header it was still not fixed.
It's still not fixed last week just of them
were in ranges I think was it ranges OK.
Because there was like destructor order
is intentional or something like that.
Yeah.
Yeah, cleaning is ignoring constraints
on when there's multiple destructors,
it just takes the first one.
So yeah, we have.
The destructor order is significant comment.
He he does have the ordering
correct, but these are.
But this case is slightly different
because the non trivial destructor is
also disabled by constraints which wasn't
the case for our other occurrences.
OK, I will add a separate comment for
that because that is so much fun.
It's gonna be really hard to describe.
Yeah yeah, I come with the
destructor of the copy constructor.
I assume it affects the copy
constructor and the move constructor
the same as it does the destructor.
OK, since they're all special member
functions, that might be mistaken.
And did ask about the planning bug,
where the order of special
member functions is significant.
When they are constrained and.
Sometimes trivial,
is that a good well description I
could see it being just destructor,
yes, but it might be just destructors
because beforehand like you could
always have multiple constructors.
That was always fine.
Yeah, multiple constructors
is a very new thing.
Yeah, this does say this does
have them in the right order,
so the destructor won't be affected.
OK, so basically if he's got
client coverage of the copy
constructor and the move constructor
and the test and I assume.
That's present then we probably
don't need to worry about this.
It does seem to be specific to destructor.
I'm so glad that you can get help now.
Coming on the destructor.
At a minimum we should have test
coverage and maybe this comment too.
Even if he's got the right order right now.
If it's doing the same sort of thing,
yeah, yeah. I would like to have
the comment on the disruptor.
OK, that's just a reminder,
but he's reading ahead. Uh.
No special member functions.
OK, here we go. I am.
Should I comment on the whole thing?
We were just the first one.
OK, Casey reminded us of the.
Complicate the clean bug.
Where the order of constrained
structures is, CF Kent.
The order you have here
here is to be correct,
but one I believe we should have
the same comment here as this.
Is equally affected.
Should we ask for test coverage too or?
This coverage for is trivially destructible.
Should get this right. Yes.
3rd we have is trivially destructible.
Bridge. OK. Casey reminded us
of the Clean bug where the order
constraint destructors is significant.
Transition elvian block destructor
order significant the order you
have here appears to be correct,
but one I believe we should have
the same common here as this code
pattern is equally affected and two,
we should ensure that we have is
trivially destructible test coverage.
OK in our never ending quest
to provide a more conformant
experience than the compilers are
capable of currently providing.
OK, Where was I?
I was at these constructors.
OK so we got through the default constructor.
Now the copy constructor.
We've commented on the morning.
I did not quite look at
the no except condition,
so we have a constexpr copy constructor
that is no except when is no throw
copy construct will be high and is
no throw copy construct with the
error that is indeed strengthened.
Requires that were correctly to Morgan,
that would be good. And.
Move to these have to be copy
constructible and copy constructible
T and copy constructible East.
OK, that's correct.
So that's the this bit.
Here and then, if it's true,
direct non list initializes
Val with DFR tests.
Otherwise direct non list
initializes unexpected error.
OK, so copy over our has
value restore claim format.
If has value stood construct
at the address of value with
other value otherwise unexpected
with other unexpected.
OK.
And I was mentally thinking does construct
that achieve the direct non list initializes?
Yes, it does. So that is good.
OK then, here's the trivial one.
This one was right. Yes, OK then the
move is going to be pretty similar.
Umm? Interesting that the move.
I guess move is a little
bit different constraints.
Both of them got to be movable,
OK, trivial, OK, same sort of deal.
Here's the 205 Casey mentioned move
seed or conditional accept here I'm
checking for copy paste errors because
it's very tempting to copy and paste the
copy constructor to the move constructor.
But then if anything was not updated,
that's a bug.
So is no throwing move constructible
T and is no throw move constructable.
E OK strengthened again.
Got it correctly to Morgan.
And his move constructible T
and is move constructible? OK,
that's good copy of the load step required.
Is the notebook required?
It is, yes, it is good point.
Good catch.
It is not strengthen.
This one is required because no
except on move constructors is more
important than on constructors, so.
OK, let's see.
That's an excellent catch and I missed it I.
Just look right past it.
So I'm very glad you caught.
Easy Carter noticed that this
exception specification is mandated
by the standard and therefore should
not be commented as strengthened.
I'm like man, I'm I'm clearly
slipping if I'm not noticing.
Like you know, the one incorrect
comment in a sea of repetitive code.
What's happening to me? Thank you.
OK, so you don't make one pass
through this and instantly
see every single thing wrong.
OK, so if it's true,
direct non initialized with stud move,
otherwise did move and then post conditions.
The write has value is unchanged so
we do not clear out the right value.
We just move from its guts.
So copying has value is correct and
then we stood construct that stood
address the value or unexpected stood
move other value or other unexpected.
OK that's all good.
We've got a semi colon there
though and that is not.
Correct or not necessary and
is not correct elsewhere,
so I will get the single character
typo before anybody else notices it.
This semi colon is unnecessary.
I still got it. OK,
hopefully I can find more significant bugs.
Yeah, that unnecessary select.
Then the move seed or turning
off cling format.
It's interesting,
I'm OK with that,
not naming it, which is good.
We've got the requires trivially move
T and trivially move error defaulted,
that's fine.
Yes, and that's going to copy over the value,
move all that it's not going to try
to zero out the value or anything,
so that's so good. OK, wow, then we
got a big set of conversions or tasks.
That's all this, so it's just
mirroring what the standard says.
This is fun. OK, so this is the
conditionally explicit converting
copy and converting move constructor.
Let's see if we can read the standards
and see what it's trying to do.
I think it's going to be a little
more natural than it appears.
So if you are converting from
an unexpected of different value
type different error type.
Then for the first overload,
let you off because you ref or just
you let GF be constant GF or just G.
OK so you got these things exist when my
value is constructible from the value
of the right as viewed through either
the consciousness or the move Ness.
That's what this is doing and.
The thing itself had better not
be an expected. Why is that?
Because expected is constructible
from at directly yeah here,
so we don't want this to ever compete with.
Is this handling like expected of expected?
Tea had better not be or
no can't be conversions.
T had better not be constructible
from expected, because if it were we
don't want to convert the whole thing.
We want to redirect essentially to this one.
OK, so this is essentially
preventing ambiguity.
Honestly, as complicated as the
set of constraints seems to be,
I am so happy that WG 21 is paying
attention to the constraints needed
for highly templated constructors.
Because stood tuple which has.
Very complicated overload set
had tremendously ambiguous.
Constructor is back in the TR1 era and
it took many years of cleanup before
they became completely unambiguous.
I think even now there's a couple LW
issues that are still being resolved.
I'm very happy to see that expected.
It is getting all this right
as of the first version,
so it had better not be
constructible from expected either.
L value R value counts or modifiable.
It had better not be implicitly.
Convertible, OK.
The ref ref here on the left
I think is unnecessary.
Look like an expect.
Yeah, I don't wanna see you at all
if you're on unexpended, expect.
And then similarly here.
Unexpected of E had better not be
constructible from expected of you and G.
Why is this?
Don't we control these classes?
That is strange. Where are these?
Is that for like, an unexpected,
unexpected and then yeah,
yeah it might be because yeah, I don't see.
There's no like direct conversions,
but I think that is what it's defending
against unexpected of expected,
which would be very confusing.
OK yeah, but I think it might
actually be able to come up right?
Hmm? Because you have.
Well, it's kind of an error
success situation, isn't it?
And this is where you want to
initialize with the unexpected.
OK, in any event,
the the standard list these requirements,
we just need to implement them.
I'm convinced that they were trying.
Like library evolution will talk
extensively and actually library classic
would have talked extensively about this.
So if all of these conditions are met then.
Forward the value otherwise
forward the error.
UM, aren't just as unchanged.
There was expressions and then the
expression site explicit is equivalent
to not convertible or not convertible.
OK, so if either of these are
not implicitly convertible,
then the whole thing needs to be explicit.
OK, this is really nice.
This is an example of why conditional
explicit just dramatically minimizes the
amount of code and standards we need.
Otherwise we would need to
replicate all this nonsense twice.
For both explicit and non explicit,
and have additional constraints,
which would be awful.
OK, so Misco is extracting all
of this lovely standard ease
into a long set of requirements.
He's calling. It is not convertible.
But this is a static constexpr
ruled within expected itself,
so I'm OK with having a fairly terse name.
If this were top level,
I would really want that name
to be longer because it sounds.
Doesn't sound like it has anything
to do with expected itself,
but because it is specific to expect it.
I think I'm OK with this.
OK, so it's templated on Utah and new error,
which are the you and G.
Instead, constable equals and
then we expect all this to match.
Let's see if this is cracked.
Here's an highlighting.
OK, so we start off with. I am.
T&amp;UF no those UF ones must be specific
to the constructors because it
varies between the copy of the move,
so it's just the common stuff.
Here OK here we go.
So all these things need to
be let me erase this garbage.
All these need to be false.
Every single one's gotta be false,
so that's why all these need to be
not and OK. So we're looking for.
Use constructible V for
the first set of four.
The T from either expected of you and G,
which is UD&amp;U error ref
or the non ref version.
Or the constraints or the constar value?
And then the next set is is convertible,
which confusingly reverses the parameters.
So the sense is different, so that's
why the time now appears on the right.
So you get expected L Ruff.
RF there, this exactly matches the standard,
even though I claim that this RF
should not appear in the standard,
I'm OK with mirroring what the
standard says in this case.
We we have asked previously to
omit the RIFRAFF in other cases,
but these set of constraints is so
complicated I'm inclined to say let's
just do what the standard says. OK.
If we were simpler, I'd be like, yeah,
let's be a little inventive there.
The rationale there is when type
traits are specified in terms of Deco Val.
Ref ref.
Is not necessary because Deco
Val will implicitly add it.
And here we know decals added on
the right and on the left right of
constructible and left of convertible.
But if the standard did it work?
Again, UU error.
This is all good and then
finally unexpected of E.
That's our error versus expected
of UD&amp;U error.
Either ref or not constant ref or not.
OK exactly mirrors the standard wonderful.
OK, this is depicted.
The one thing I noticed.
This is depicted in terms of a
long chain of variable templates.
We could in theory convert this to a
conjunction of negation of is constructible,
which would be more verbose.
Admittedly, it could potentially
allow the compiler to short circuit.
However, I don't know if that would really
buy a lot of throughput compiler speed,
because if it doesn't short circuit
the sort of ultimate time is the same.
The short circuiting only
happens when considering.
This thing which looks like it
converting constructor and wanting
it to defer to another constructor.
Which seems uncommon.
When Ty is actually constructible
from expected and so forth.
Like all these conditions are possible,
but they're pretty whacky coda,
I think,
has to be pretty pathological
for any of these to be relevant,
which argues in favor of just
directly writing it,
like Misco has,
rather than writing the more
convoluted but potentially faster
throughput version with conjunction.
I'm OK with this. I strongly prefer this.
OK,
if it ever turns out to be through problem,
we can revisit with conjunction.
Otherwise sounds good.
OK, thanks Charlie.
OK, so with that,
let's take a look here.
OK,
so now we're going to see the
remaining constraints.
It's a little narrow.
OK, so we've got template on
Utah and new error requires.
So here's these first
constraints that we want to see.
Our time needs to be constructible from
Conce Utah ref because this is the copy.
Yeah you ref. And error needs to be
constructible from constitute error ref OK.
And, uh, we should not be
convertible from Utah and new error.
OK, that's very nice then.
Context for conditional, explicit
and then the conditional explicit is.
We should see not convertible
UFT or not convertible GFE's OK.
Not convertible from Consulte
RAF to Thai correct or not.
Convertible consume erft error correct.
OK this is the copy constructor converting
copy from other or conditionally no
except when is no throw constructible
V tie from construed ref and is no
throw constructible error from consu ref.
The copy is strengthened
and so will the move,
cause it's not an actual move constructor.
OK, copy over the has value.
If has value then do the construct add.
Otherwise do the unexpected construct add OK,
that's good.
OK, going a little faster now.
Your error OK here we want to see not the
counts draff but just the plain type Utah.
And constructible error you error and
not convertible Utah you error good
constexpr simplicit not convertible from.
Let's see where that tier.
OK yeah, we get the UU first so U Thai
Thai or not convertible ur error.
OK, that's correct.
Converting move constructor conditional no,
except that strengthened time needs to
be nothrow constructible from Utah.
No construct and no throw constructible
error from you error correct
copy that has value, but then.
Forward, not move forward.
That's this year.
Utai and you error excellent.
OK, that's the converting copy move.
Now we have the Utah reference struct.
OK, just a little simpler.
Can we back up for a second?
Ohh sure you should forward
instead of move here.
Yeah, that's uhm to these be reference types.
That's a good question.
The standard uses for when they
could be reference types has
expected forbidden reference types.
I think it required object types, didn't it?
I thought so, yeah, but I'm not seeing it.
There there were all the the
static assertions unexpected.
I thought they would be here year ago.
My program that instantiates the
definition of template expected TE for a
reference type or blah blah blah is bad,
so we've already enforced that.
It's good,
that's a good point if we don't
worry about reference types,
then forward buys us nothing.
It should be moved in the standard.
There's yeah, only lvalue
references and rvalue references
could make that a problem, but.
It's not a problem here.
And that buying that's binding
on both the type and the error.
So unless they were trying to
like reserve space for the future,
that's not necessary.
I'm OK with doing what
the standard says here,
but it does seem that there should
be an editorial issue about.
In this case,
because it is within expected,
it's not some arbitrary here.
These could just be moved.
If we switch them ohh I
see I see right to doing.
It's the specification shortcut.
Here, they're specifying both the
copy and the converting move by
condensing them in terms of UF.
So if you're going to do this,
you do need forward to add
the cost you roughness.
Otherwise just get you,
but if they split this out and said
just access RHS dot Val or move
stood move from RHS dot Val then you
wouldn't need to see the forward,
but because they've specified
things in terms of UF,
forward is the correct way to handle it.
In the implementation, it could
be a move. That's interesting.
Should we ask for a move there?
This more closely mirrors the standardise,
and it's not wrong.
It's not doing exactly what
the standard is doing so.
You know that mirroring the
standards is a great argument. Yeah,
I think I think move is reasonable here.
I I would kind of like a move here, OK?
Just to make it clear that this
is always a move always,
effectively move.
OK, let's see.
If you want to replace all
of them with static casts.
The difference between moving
forward is very important.
Notes that although this technically
mirrors the standard ease,
the standard is taking a shortcut
by specifying the converting copy
and converting move ctors together
with whatever they called UF&amp;GF.
Command chief. Umm? The. It's packed.
Has already forbidden reference type
reference types. So when you know.
We're implementing the converting.
I'm trying to be careful here because
the converting move sedor is not
an actual move constructor as far
as the core language is concerned.
So when we know we're implementing
the converting move seed,
or we can simply say stood move.
The. Reserve on all,
say congratulations conventionally.
Reserve stood forward in the
implementation only for perfect forwarding.
Or situations like hair. Where?
Handling reference types is.
Necessary OK, how does that sound?
Casey notes that although this
technically mirrors the standard,
is the standard is taking a shortcut
by specifying the converting copy
and converting Moors together
with Ugf expected has already
forbidden reference types,
so when we know we're implementing
the converting moved or we
can simply say stood move.
We conventionally reserve stood forward
in the implementation only for perfect
forwarding or situations like pair.
We're handling reference types as necessary.
Cool, if somebody wanted
to use the mirroring.
The standard wording argument.
I would point out that they didn't
mirror the standard wording.
Empty constructor above the copy converting.
Yeah, they're hard. So good point.
I like it. OK, let's see.
I think we have time to look
at one more constructor,
which is this ulefone. OK so.
Claim form it off on because we've got
the requires there template on class
U = T and then we got the constraints.
So these constraints here are
a little involved so if I can
get them on the same page.
This has to be false,
not the same V.
Remove CVF tuty in place T better not
be an in place T and not the same V.
OK, he's swapping the sides here,
but that's OK. Uhm, expected of us,
so that's just expected.
The injected class name as remove
CV ref to fu. OK, that's good and.
Uh, because we know, is Sandia symmetric.
Remove CVT of you is not a
specialization of unexpected.
This really should be a standard
trait and is constructable.
Vtu is true.
OK that's good and the requires is good.
Is that an empty comment that's
wrapping it is that is not necessary
in a claim form and off block.
Umm the?
Empty comment is unnecessary.
In fact, I once failed the
spelling because I couldn't spell
necessary is unnecessary in this
playing format all block. OK.
And continuing.
OK, constexpr explicit.
Yet we are explicit when
not is convertible V.
You to T OK expected construct from
UDF other and then we're strengthening.
He is no through constructiv tie.
That's our tie from Udy.
OK, that's good. So then we direct
non initialize Val the value.
And we always have a value,
so we can just mention it in the
list with stood forward to you.
OK, so it has value.
True, that looks good.
Uh, is that the correct order?
I'm gonna check, I know we've got
compiler warnings now about the order.
I'm surprised that has
value would occur last.
Where is the data member?
Oht is it is last we've got the
Union and then the has value.
OK, that's good.
And we were. Here. OK, and then we've got.
Constructors for unexpected OK and pull up.
OK so I will copy this to
remind myself where I am.
OK, it looks like we have gotten through
maybe about 100 lines of class expected.
I will have to continue
reviewing this offline,
but we saw a lot of great stuff today.
Great catches from everyone.
Thank you for finding all of this stuff.
I will go ahead and submit these comments.
I guess I am requesting changes
so I will say request changes.
And I'll submit a comment
so I can collapse it later.
GitHub does not let you collapse
things that are submitted within
the review itself.
OK.
I thought I deleted this.
Did I not delete this comment?
I think it might not have
deleted it oopsie. Umm?
I'll comment on this. This is the Annex 1.
Never mind here, on X is
displayed as a data member of.
Expected and although
it's not the name of the.
Exposition only numbers or
what was that? Unexpected.
And bad. Expected access
that seems clear enough.
OK think about ax, yeah,
never mind here on X is latest
date member of expected and that's
not the name of the expedition.
Only members for unexpecting bad
expect access. It seems clear. OK.
We've got the easiness pistol,
the auto, the can we use auto rifraf.
I don't name the parameter.
The Morgan and extra currents and test
and comment about the destructive order.
This one is standard and this semi
colon forwarding empty comment OK.
Note to self.
Partially previewed.
I keep typing expected.
It's gonna keep happening.
To including this.
So let me see review this.
Progress is monotonically nondecreasing.
OK, partially you had expected
up to and including expected
you to refer further.
Still need to review test mention
that it's a video review.
OK, there we go.
Comments are submitted.
Let's see, have there been
any questions in the chat?
I will stop sharing my screen.
And check. OK, Cameron jokes.
I think it's fair to say that this
review has taken longer than expected.
Nice one.
Uh, OK Casey's got some comments
about traveling Meow concepts that
would be nice because concepts
have that subsumption thing,
where if you constrain with a
concept that the compiler can see is
stricter in some sense than another,
it's considered to subsume
the smaller concept,
and overload resolution recognizes that,
which is awesome.
That's something that's fine,
does not get sphene,
is just like, oh,
you're throwing a bunch of tools
at the compiler and you need
to very carefully construct
your overload set so that.
Exactly one of those overloads
lights up and the rest are disabled
by the Phoenix with concepts
you just constrain them all,
and then as long as the
concepts are arranged properly,
the compiler can see in a process
that is either partial ordering or
very similar to partial ordering.
That,
oh,
this one is the most specific because it
wants is trivially fancy constructible
now rather than just Disney now,
so it'll select the better one.
Much like having a more template.
Or if you've got a bunch of
overloads like pair of TU pair of T,
star T star pair of in Star double star,
the compiler will select the most
specific one that's always been
baked into overload resolution.
Having that in concepts is very nice.
So yeah,
I agree that having concepts.
That sort of supersede the
type traits that would be good.
And then Cameron hypothesizes having
a concept of capture if all teams are
trivial would be a good abstraction.
Yeah,
seems reasonable.
OK,
looking through the comments,
some comment about the exception
specifications and the auto ref
ref which we all talked about.
OK,
I think that's everything
that was brought up.
Let me know if I'm missing anything.
OK,
I think that's it so we can
call this a code review.
Thanks for watching Part 2 of this.
There may be a part three
depending on how quickly we get
through the rest of expected.
In any event,
we'll see you next time.